okay there are people very eager to get
on and ask some questions the phone
number is six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty let's start today with
our caller from the 8:06 area code who's
calling today from eight zero six hey
David are you good who's this this is
David Corona I'm actually located and
Noel pestle
really okay well interesting to hear
from you what's going on hey so do you
think now after these unfortunate mass
shooting here do you think Republicans
well now that they have more pressure to
pass a bill to centralize the background
checks do you think that Mitch McConnell
will come back and pass a clean bill do
you think they're going to try to tie it
to an immigration bill that Trump wants
to we're already seeing that the idea
floated of tying it to an immigration
bill which I think is is disgusting and
wrongheaded I've seen that it it seems
as though Republicans are sort of coming
around on the idea of these red flag
laws which are quite frankly I mean
there's just so much more that needs to
be done but I do generally agree with
you that it seems that the pressure at
this point is getting to the point where
they'll have to do something it may end
up getting them more of what they want
on immigration though if they
successfully tie it so I mean it's just
a complete and total mess quite frankly
David I agree I think they are gonna try
to tie it to an immigration on 14th
probably will not pass I what's
happening locally there in El Paso like
what's the local conversation about gun
laws that that's happening now in the
wake of what of the shooting everyone's
on board that we need to to centralize
the background we need to have more
thorough background check whether it's
kind of make it more like the like the
getting your concealed where you have to
go through a class you have to renew you
have to you know of course not be a
felon as you continue to renew I think
that's what that's all who I talked to
that to what they are on board
I want to do even Republicans that I was
going to say I'm sure tell me can you
say there or do you know whether
Republicans also want that in El Paso oh
yeah I've I've talked to one yesterday
he was on board with background checks
that he he was definitely on board to do
that to pass a clean bill but
unfortunately he he he watches hawk news
and he was trying to say well it's
emma-crats always go too far and try to
do like a weapons ban but we know from
the past has always been clean bill to
try to pass for background checks and
it's always just that in the Senate yeah
hey let me ask you this you mentioned
talking to a Republican in El Paso who
watches Fox News is that Republican
aware of what was in the shooters
manifesto or has that information not
even gotten to him I didn't ask okay the
reason the reason why is because he look
he's a co-worker God and he's a
supervisor at that so I didn't want to
be confrontational he is one that will
be confrontational I've seen them before
but I wanted to kind of get his what he
thought about it and what he was on
board with changing and so he's on board
with that more thorough background check
okay yeah I mean that's not surprising
and that's one of those things where
after the Sandy Hook shooting there was
like 88 or 85% support for that and you
know it still didn't get done so it's
actually not that surprising it seems a
lot of Republicans see that as a
relatively minor infringement that they
would be sort of happy to accept if not
that much more is done you know what I
mean
exactly yeah David really your call are
you gonna go enjoy a rope did you see it
yeah did are you saying am I gonna be
bad yeah you're gonna go back on e time
I would love to but there's nothing
scheduled right now
okay good alright then I appreciate it
okay thanks David yep best of luck down
in port Angelo thank you appreciate that